dr. forest tenant has run a pain clinic
out of an office in this West Covina
California strip mall since the 1970s
the clinic's decor is as decidedly
old-school as the physician who runs it
but chronic pain patients from around
the country flocked to the 76 year old
doctor to get treatment they can't seem
to get anywhere else
you just can't depend on an oral pill
because I have patients that come in
here from Maine and Miami in other words
from all over and including Alaska tough
patients like Lois Ogden 67 years old
who's dealt with chronic pain for almost
as long as he can remember if you can
imagine making a mold of my head that's
1/4 inch too small all the way around
every direction and then putting it on
and it was having it free every right
louis's chronic pain prevented him and
his wife and high school sweetheart
kristin from living a normal life for
decades we were involved in an almost
non-stop pursuit of help saw many
different specialists and tried many
medications and therapies and treatments
but nothing ever really helped the
Ogden's briefly found a local doctor in
Virginia who gave Lois what he needed a
high dose of opioid pain pills after we
finally got to the right drugs I'm able
to live my life more or less as a normal
person whereas prior to that I was
practically Houseman
but Louis's doctor was later arrested on
charges of over prescribing William
Hurwitz a pain specialist who was
sentenced to 25 years in prison for drug
trafficking every doctor in Virginia yes
unless there's pressure on prescribers
especially in Montana and so I think
that the writing is on the wall they're
becoming more fearful what people most
people don't know is that the chronic
pain sufferer is out there not getting
treated this is so out of control and
it's on an unbelievable scale it's
bizarre what's happening across our
country right now
drunk makers in the opioid crisis
epidemic yep another big-time opiate
epidemic a commodious like you netted
emic of addiction to opioids the opioid
overdose epidemic is killing as many as
91 Americans a day according to the
Center for Disease Control many doctors
have been arrested for running so-called
pill mills and turning patients into
addicts the DEA in the Hamilton Boone
Drug Task Force arrested 11 people dr.
Richard R an arrested in San Francisco
don't roll over fatigue under a reactor
was arrested along with 12 and in 2016
the DEA clamped down on painkillers
reducing the allowed production of
opioid medications by 25 percent or more
this year the CDC issued guidelines
advising doctors to avoid prescribing
high doses over 90 morphine milligram
equivalents so maybe it's no surprise
that it's a boundary pusher like tenant
who's one of the last doctors in America
willing to take patients who say they
need a high dose of pain medication to
function the rare cases in the other
states are really very dish cast out
totally tenant is never shied from the
public spotlight in addition to briefly
serving as mayor of his city he ran some
of Los Angeles County's earliest
methadone clinics to treat heroin
addicts and in the late 80s served as a
drug adviser for the NFL NASCAR and the
Los Angeles Dodgers controversy swirled
around him in many of these roles he
angered the NFL when he publicly
disclosed plans to monitor several New
England Patriots players for drug use
one NASCAR racer even accused him of
colluding to falsified drug tests to
target him after resigning Tennant told
the New York Times that no mistakes were
ever made during his time in politics
Tennant was instrumental in pushing
forward the pain patients Bill of Rights
in California which explicitly spells
out that opiates can be a safe and
effective form of pain treatment Tennant
acknowledges that opioids were over
prescribed in the past and should
generally be a last resort for pain
treatment but he believes the media and
government
now gone too far in demonizing them and
it's legitimate pain patients who are
paying the price once you start opioid
drugs this idea that you can just quit
them and it's your pain will gold
magically go away is a mist there are
people who can take opioid drug at a
very high dose for many years they've
the first doctors who ever said our goal
is to relieve your pain every other
doctor had said our goal is to get you
off any opioid medications the pressure
has even affected the way doctors think
about pain the American Medical
Association recommended in 2016 the
doctors no longer ask patients to rate
their pain I take the Hippocratic oath
services and my job is to relieve pain
and suffering so when I see somebody
like the AMA decide they're not going to
assess pain I'm not with them in a
recent New England Journal of Medicine
article one of the pain specialists who
advised the CDC on their guidelines
recommended that pain patients use
coping and acceptance strategies that
primarily reduce the suffering
associated with pain and only
secondarily reduce pain intensity that
pain is psychological
that needs to go out the window let me
tell you why because you're looking at
the guy he's probably done most of the
studies I start checking out with viral
titers autoimmune tests we find
biochemical physiological changes in the
body and we can now track down where
that's coming from
so these people who are being labeled
psychological is just a ploy to not
treat the patient and to try to blame
the patient rather than the medical
system who is rejecting them yet an
underreported fact is that pain patients
aren't the problem when it comes to
opioid abuse and addiction in America a
study from the Cochrane review found
that when legitimate pain patients are
screened for prior addiction issues
fewer than 1% ever become addicted to
opioids they're trying to give the idea
that we can't tell the difference
between the addict and the legitimate
pain patient simply not true it's easy
to do Tennant's believes the country
needs more pain specialists like him who
are willing to take the difficult cases
and challenge the emerging conventional
wisdom that opioids can't treat pain the
effort to completely discredit opioids
is a legitimate treatment option he says
will only lead to more pain resentment
and tragedy you just can't throw
legitimate good solid citizens who have
pain start calling them addicts and
start calling them subs abuse orders
disorders and you're starting to develop
great resentment in these people against
their government against the media I
consider the intentional removal of
effective pain medication it's a
deliberate action to inflict pain on
someone that's the definition of torture
we're tired of the battle tired of
fighting with the insurance companies
tired of fighting with the doctors to
describe what we go through every day
the suffering is inhumane
and this is just a medication to treat
pain it is not the first line of
medication when I read the CBC
guidelines and other government
issuances when I hear the politician
speak it says bill people like him do
not exist at all it's as though you're
invisible
[Music]
[Music]